the people of Puerto Rico still hadn't
recovered from Hurricane Maria which hit
five years ago now once again dealing
with wide-ranging damage
U.S President Joe Biden and Jill Biden
traveled there Monday he said to send a
message this U.S territory will not be
forgotten after Maria
Congress approved billions of dollars
for Puerto Rico much of it not having
gotten here initially we're going to
make sure you get every single dollar
promised and I'm determined to help
Puerto Rico build faster than in the
past and stronger and better prepared
for the future he was referring to
former president Donald Trump who
withheld almost 20 billion dollars of
Aid meant for the island and Biden said
in addition to emergency aid he will
also be sending an additional 60 billion
dollars to help strengthen the
infrastructure against future storms and
in the State of Florida the destruction
is still coming to light in large parts
of the state everything seems out of
place boats on land cars in water houses
simply missing the floors are are ruined
the walls are down the ceilings have all
dropped down the water level is above
the roof the whole thing is this is
everything we could sell which is our
lives there are new questions about why
people in the hardest hit County were
not told to evacuate until a day before
the storm hit local officials are
defending their actions we did what we
had to do at the exact same time I
wouldn't have changed anything and I
know being in those meetings from the
very minute this storm was very
unpredictable searches are still
underway with 1900 people rescued so far
but as the death toll reaches 100
officials say that number is likely to
rise Paddy culhane Al Jazeera